hey Letterman Leno and Stewart grow a
pair comedians are constantly saying
that unlike the last eight years the
current administration is just too hard
to make fun of and of course mainstream
media shares the same views really I
mean we've all seen what happens with
Bhama when there's a teleprompter
malfunction he does charming little
things like thank himself in his own
speeches and make fun of handicaps but
putting all that aside you really can't
find anything funny about this
administration when Joe freakin Biden as
vice president the guy himself said that
Hillary Clinton would have been a better
choice it's like having Rain Man as vice
president yeah definitely
that'd definitely make a better VP than
Joe Biden Hillary Clinton Rain Man make
better VP than Joe Biden yeah to 256
hair plugs
I can't even picture Joe Biden carrying
out daily mundane tasks let alone begin
to imagine how he'd react to the current
economic crisis he must have some kind
of handler
[Applause]
it's okay all right yeah I'm here okay
Tuesday's Wapner the economy is
collapsing yeah
Qantas Qantas never crashed yeah what
your company's crumbling and you are
talking about Quartus oh yeah of course
I'm an X course I'm an excellent driver
the problem with Biden is he just can't
seem to keep its mouth shut and it
embarrasses everybody around him yeah of
course
Chris Barack Obama did cocaine in
college and wrote communist poetry yeah
shut up shut up Jill we even talk about
those things okay can you stop putting
your foot in your mouth Joe of course of
course everybody messes with Joe blimey
five-time five-time deferments from
Vietnam everybody messes with Joe Biden
let's take a look at some of Biden's
gaps that you probably haven't heard of
a three-letter word jobs
Jay Oh b s jobs
stand up Chuck let them see ya Joe Biden
said this to a Missouri State Senator
Chuck Ram oh yeah and Chuck is bound to
a wheelchair
stand up jugs let them see you uh-uh oh
crap and lastly my personal favorite you
cannot go into a 7-eleven or Dunkin
Donuts unless you have a slight Indian
accent what oh uh can you imagine what
the media would have done if anyone in
the Bush administration had said
something like this they would have been
shot at dawn before breakfast I don't
know am I being too hard on these guys
or do you guys think this administration
is short of getting a free pass let me
know please oh and I almost forgot
you might wanna have your kids leave the
room for this next part Joe Biden was
recently caught saying into a hot
microphone give me a break oh oh bad
word